hey here's an interesting side story
from the Iowa caucus Pete Budaj
is a gay man and this is known to a lot
of people and it is wholly irrelevant to
me in thinking about whether I agree
with Pete Budaj edges policies
there's viral video that has been
released of a voter in a rural part of
Iowa on Monday night who realized after
submitting her vote in the caucus for
Pete Budaj that he is a gay man and that
he has a same-sex partner and starts
asking to take her vote back a precinct
captain for Pete has a conversation with
her the video going completely viral
take a look the Bible is raised and
actually the precinct captain does a
pretty good job of dealing with that
talking point by saying listen we we
weren't around when it was written and
we don't really know what the intention
was and the conversation continues
[Music]
because why does it say in the Bible
that a man should marry a woman men
you're viewing on and I so totally do
but I think that we were not around then
run out before college so this is
important the fact that this woman had
never heard that Pete is gay is that a
sign of progress what I mean by that is
if sexual orientation is not part of the
discussion around a candidate and it's
not part of this woman's awareness you
could say that that's progress in the
sense that it simply was not a big
enough deal among voters that sexual
orientation was playing a big role in
figuring out who you want to support now
the the thing about it is this woman is
wearing Amy Klobuchar stickers
she was probably there supporting Amy
and then went to Pete after the first
round or whatever the case may be it may
not really be an indication that most
people aren't aware of mayor pete being
gay or whatever i don't know how big of
a sign of anything it really is but in
my mind if it becomes irrelevant what
one sexual orientation is in terms of
whether someone would support them it
feels as though it is a step forward to
some degree here's a little bit more of
the video
right now is where it all just a look
inside your heart because you sound like
you must not believe it then if you
think it's okay for somebody to marry to
a same-sex I think we're just
interpreting it different and that's
okay everybody but I teach my son is
really interesting stuff there were
initially some allegations that this was
staged in some way there's no evidence
of that whatsoever
from what I've read the voter did
ultimately get her card back and was
able to switch her vote to Elizabeth
Warren from Mayor Pete on that second
round there's an interesting sort of
policy question here is there any
candidate that opposes same-sex marriage
at this point and I'm not even talking
about on the Democratic side Trump even
seems fine with same-sex marriage so you
know is is the problem support of
same-sex marriage because the voter says
the Bible talks about marriage between
being between a man and a woman
Pete is married to a man and supports
same-sex marriage all the other
candidates are heterosexual but they
support same-sex marriage Donald Trump
is heterosexual but seems okay with
same-sex marriage at least to the extent
that he's not made it any kind of a
problem is the problem being gay in the
eyes of this voter or is it supporting
same-sex marriage I don't know and then
of course remember the Bible says don't
eat shellfish don't wear mixed fabric
clothing I don't know how many
candidates are abiding by those rules
either so a very strange and sort of
interesting video and I my view on this
is I don't care what anyone's sexual
orientation is I care about their
political positions because of that I'm
not a mayor Pete guy but what I'm
curious about is do we see it as a sign
of progress that mayor Pete sexual
orientation is unknown to a lot of
people or do we see it as an uninformed
electorate I don't know I open it up to
you one of our sponsors today is VIN
Chara watches giving you 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great because you don't
have to all of inch arrows watches are
made with high-end materials masterfully
built and they look like something you'd
spend a ton of money on but every
venture Oh watch ranges from about a
hundred and fifty to three hundred bucks
I went over to their website and picked
out the bellwether in silver and white
really nice elegant look it's a
coronagraph style wore it to a gala over
the weekend and a lot of people ask me
where's the watch from really really
great look totally different they also
sent me the altitude in matte black and
red a much more rugged view of what a
watch can look like really liked it as
well as well as the athletic strap it's
a new year it's a new decade it's time
to re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch